we are sportive this morning and we've
got a sportive single best Chuck who's
probably matters tom yesterday the
greeley family wats journey let's slip
its first half dominance against norway
in the women's world cup of course as
you all know that game came out at I
wonderfully each in the group round this
morning I came to work and I had to
explain to Tom why this matters that is
the subject of today's single best chart
Tom here's what we're looking at the the
the fat bars are non world cup game
attendance here Women's World Cup excuse
me women's soccer team attendance at the
games here in the US right it's going up
it's either the white bars in the middle
those are World Cup years and what we're
seeing is both are going up we're seeing
non world cup year attendance video up
and World Cup your attendance has soared
so here's what's going on Fox is
committed four hundred and twenty six
million dollars to the whole world cup
project through through 20-26 they've
got to make something out of this
they're running ads they have a 15
million dollar campaign on this they're
going into elementary schools to
introduce kids the women's world cup
team it is working one of the things
that you really notice when you're
watching the games is that there's
attendance at the US games that is
incomparable to attendance at the other
game and I just point out a does hope
that it's in canada where the shower is
actually very cheap right now well yes
of course and it helps that it's in
canada where that's our that's a
conceivable trip right you can imagine
slipping across the border to go see a
soccer game it's a little harder
thinking about going to Brazil